in this video we're going to discuss the
naturalization process
which non-citizens go through in order
to gain their u.s
citizenship heads up that we won't be
talking about the
eligibility requirements that
non-citizens must meet
or any of the challenges that they might
face along the path to naturalization
we'll cover those in other videos this
is just an
overview of what happens at each step in
the process
if a non-citizen wants to start the
naturalization process
the first step is for them to determine
if they are eligible to become
a u.s citizen then they have to wait
if they are married to a current u.s
citizen
they have to wait three years if they
are not
they have to wait five years during this
time
many immigrants take special classes to
prepare for citizenship
after the waiting period if they are at
least 18 years old
and have been a resident of the state
where they intend to
file for at least three months they may
file an application for naturalization
an
n-400 once they've submitted their
application
they must attend a biometrics
appointment to have their fingerprints
added to their records
then they'll have to complete an
interview with an official from u.s
citizenship
and immigration services to ensure that
they meet the necessary requirements
and to conduct the naturalization exam
the exam has two parts an english
language test
with questions about reading writing and
speaking english
and a civics test with 10 questions on
basic facts about the history and
government of the united states
if the applicant gets 6 of the 10
questions right
they pass and their application is
approved
the final step in the naturalization
process is to attend a ceremony to
pledge an oath of allegiance
the non-citizen swears to be loyal to
the united states above
all to obey the constitution and other
laws
and to perform military or other duties
if needed
then they sign a document and are
declared a citizen of the united states
and if they have any children under the
age of 18
their children automatically become
naturalized citizens too
in the next video we'll go into more
detail about the eligibility
requirements for naturalization